hey guys in this video I'm going to talk
about faith and importance of kin whare
a red priestess squeeze one of the
high-ranked leaders in the fate of the
Lord of Light Kim are appeared in fifth
episode called the door of season six
and from only that one scene it was
pretty obvious that Kim Burrell play
major role in the upcoming seasons as we
all know Kim accepted Iran's imitation
who sent it in order to gain her
assistance in convincing people to
follow the neighbors as their protector
rather than a conquerer author Kim our
acceptance invitation she met with
Tyrion Lannister and Varys and the Great
Pyramid of Meereen
Kim our stayed silent while Tyrion
greeted her in valyrian whereupon she
said in a common tongue that he does not
need to persuade her into helping
because as king mara said herself she
believes that Daenerys is the one who
was promised using Dana's freeing of the
slaves and her dragons as an examples of
her claim I have to tell you that while
we are all expecting from the show to
reveal that Jon is the prince that was
promised it also might be Daenerys
Targaryen as I have already said in one
of my previous videos also King more is
not the only one who said that Daenerys
is the one who was promised in the books
maester aemon
pointed out that in high Valyrian which
is the language which was used in most
versions of the prophecies the word
corresponding to Prince is
gender-neutral pointing out the fact
that the prophecy is not specific about
the promised person's gender I'm not
saying that the nurse is definitely the
one who's promised but there are a lot
of matches between the nearest and
prophecy matches which some could while
a lot considering as approves depending
on how we see it
in fact the prophecy more than faith
Daenerys the prophecy says that prince
that was promised aka the one who was
promised would be quote born amidst salt
and smoke beneath the bleeding star
unquote she was born in Dragonstone an
island in the Narrow Sea meaning that we
have sold from the waves hitting the
shores of Dragonstone
and also she was reborn as a mother of
dragons on Khal Drogo's burning funeral
bonfire which matches the part of
prophecy which includes a mid smoke
also very important fact is that in the
morning for the first time the red comet
appear in the sky which fits the part
which says beneath the bleeding star for
the final confirmation of the nares
being the one who was promised we have
an additional prophecy from a votes of
which prophesized that the principles
promised will be born from the line of
Aries and Rolla as we all know this
prophecy also fits Daenerys perfectly
since Daenerys is a daughter of Eros and
relative area and Samwell Tarly told to
mainstream and rumors about the nearest
Targaryen and her dragons Amon became
certain that Dany is prophesied leader
Amon told Sam no one ever looked for a
girl it was a prince that was promised
not a princess and also told Sam that
Daenerys is the one born amidst salt and
smoke the Dragons prove it in maester
aemon's earlier life
he taught Rhaegar was the prince that
was promised as real girl was born
during the tragedy at summer hall amid
smoke of the burning castle while salt
was provided from the tears of those who
cried for those who had died but a time
Amon was wrong now that we know that
King Mara is not the only one who puts
Daenerys and the one whose promise
together let's continue in King Mara's
importance there is no doubt about
converse importance in the upcoming
seasons which we could realise only
considering how important Mills Sandra's
role has been so far and believe me when
I said that many Sandra's powers can't
even be compared to King Mara's you
might think that my statements are wrong
that are not true and I can understand
that
but let me explain why in my opinion
King viral play a big role in season
seven especially in season eight I'm
aware that Melisandre has played one of
the biggest roles
I mean without her John would have been
dead which is her biggest achievement
but also with other
Stannis would have also still been alive
while no Sandra has played a huge role
in previous seasons in my opinion as
I've said in video about when Sandra's
fate beside two big encounters that she
will probably have in season seven in my
opinion she will disappear for the most
of season whereupon she will reappear
dramatically either near the end of the
upcoming or in the
meaning of the last eight season but
it's only my opinion I could be wrong
Melisandre might be included in every
single episode but I just don't see it
that way in case I'm wrong in case that
co-producers David then they decide to
include Melisandre in most of episodes
in that case I see Melisandre in
Winterfell during the almost whole
season hiding behind her true form
theory which I brought you in a video
about Melisandre spades so if you find
this theory interesting feel free to
check it out however as I was saying Kim
R is much more powerful than Melisandre
Kim Aristotle is High Priestess of the
red temple of Atlantis the flame of
truth the light of wisdom and for a
servant of the Lord of Light which says
itself how much powerful King Mara is
vileness and raised only title is a red
priestess of the Lord of Light on the
meeting which I mentioned in the
beginning of this video in Marvel's
happy to assess the nearest associates
however she can well she and Tyrion were
just about to complete their agreement
Varys interrupted their conversation and
pointed out the Masonic had proclaimed
Stannis Baratheon to be the one that was
promised pointing out how accurate or
should I say inaccurate she was since
Danice was defeated in the Battle of
Blackwater and later at Winterfell as
well but at that time for good very soul
so stated their religion is overly
self-assured of its own tenants once
again pointing out that no one should
believe in her words when another red
priestess was wrong
after very stated all out all that was
in his mind in that very moment as we
could seek in Mara confronted him Kim
are firstly replied with the statement
that everything is the will of the Lord
but man and woman can make mistakes
pointing on else andreas mistake now
here we come to the moment which showed
us how much kingdom are a powerful
really is is the moment in which king
Mara we can call it proved and
demonstrated as well that she is not
lying when she says that she has some
special capabilities that's a scene in
which King Mara has to various about the
voice in the flames that he heard when
the second-rate sorcerer through
his main parts into the fire and also
ask him if he knows who was speaking on
the other side making very speechless
where is already visibly shaken has been
asked by King vara if he wants her to
repeat for him those same words or to
identify the speaker for him the words
which varies doesn't want to hear again
because of the fear that it brings to
him their meeting ended with King Mara
turning to leave and assured tyrion that
she will call on her best priestess and
preachers to speak about the Queen
through all of Essos let me quote one
her sentence that she told to Varys
everyone is what they are and where they
are for a reason terrible things happen
for a reason they could happen to you
Lord Varys when you were a child
if not for your mutilation hand of a
second-rate sorcerer you wouldn't be
here helping the Lord's Chosen bring his
light into the world I've been wondering
what king vara wanted to imply on when
she said if not for your mutilation you
wouldn't be here helping the Lord's
Chosen King Mara clearly man that if not
for his mutilation he wouldn't be
helping the nurse right now but I'm
wondering is it because of the voice in
the flames that Varys heard did he gain
all power that he has and he's helping
Daenerys because of the words because
the voice told him to I'm aware that
it's hard to find an accurate answer on
this but in his theory in which the
voice came out from the flames told
wares to serve him and to help the
nearest certainly is an interesting
theory at least for me well we know for
sure that fairies got his revenge as we
saw seen in fourth episode of third
season in which we could see that Varys
was clearly torching that same sorcerer
that once tortured him a scene which
explained a lot in that same scene were
submitted to Tyrion that he heard a
voice and that he still dreams of that
night the night when all of that
happened to him therefore he also
admitted that it's not because of
sorcerer or his blade that he dreams off
but because of the voice from the flames
in the books verse doesn't even know
what he heard that night when they
described the haunting story of his
castration he said that when the
sorcerer threw
his parts into the fire he heard a
strange voice speaking a language he
could not understand and also said that
he was drugged and in pain pointing out
that he often told himself that he must
have hallucinate the voice while this is
the case in the books I don't think it's
the same the show in the show we're sent
himself that he still remembers the
voice in addition he said he dreams of
it every now and then which kind of
confirms that verse knows what the voice
said and by his face expression when
king Mara asked him I'm quoting again
you heard the voice call out from the
flames
do you remember should I tell you what
the voice said it was pretty obvious
that he knows and that he exactly
understood the words that came out from
the flames but let's assume that just
like in the books first didn't
understand what the voice was saying or
the TV show as well it would still be
obvious that Varys who came in constant
as one of the most clever man at Seven
Kingdoms would learn that language on
which voice was talking would learn and
soul the meaning of those words since he
still knows and dreams of the voice and
words that came out of it so yeah it's
most likely that verse knows what the
voice said exactly and in my opinion
that same voice is reason Affairs being
on the place in which she currently is
and the reason of him helping Daenerys
Targaryen since the very beginning let's
get back to King Mara let's get back on
statement which confirms my statement
that Kumar is way more powerful than
Melisandre while the meaning was getting
between her and tearing along with very
so an end
commercial Tyrion that she will summon
her best priestess and preachers to
speak about the queen role of Essos
did you catch and figure out that
particular part of sentence in which she
said I will summon my priestesses that
means that she has higher rank compared
to someone like Melisandre as first part
of her title says itself High Priestess
of the red temple of volantis
which also supports my statement that
King Mark has more power than other
ordinary red priestesses considering how
young King Mara looks it's most likely
that she's just like Melisandre hiding
behind her true form
additionally in my opinion quinoa should
be my
children since no Sandra is only an
ordinary red priestess while king mark
has a much higher title
inclusion King Marvel in my opinion play
a huge role in the upcoming seasons
Kilmer also has much more power than the
Sandra or any other red priestess which
is kind of certain segment after all we
could call it arguments that I brought
it today let me know your opinion on all
of this in the comment section down
below
don't you think that king juarez role is
yet to come because it wouldn't kind of
make sense to bring that powerful and
important character in the show without
any further importance don't you think